.
>> HELLO, EVERYONE.
I'M ERICA HILL IN FOR KATE
BOLDUAN.
WE ARE FOLLOWING BREAKING NEWS
AT THIS HOUR.
THE U.S. SUPREME COURT HAS JUST
ISSUED A MAJOR RULING IN THE
CHALLENGE TO A NEW YORK GUN LAW.
THIS IS THE MOST SIGNIFICANT
SECOND AMENDMENT RULING IN MORE
THAN A DECADE.
IN A 6-3 DECISION, THE COURT
STRUCK DOWN NEW YORK'S LAW THAT
PLACES RESTRICTIONS ON CONCEALED
HANDGUNS .
THAT LAW WAS ENACTED MORE THAN A
CENTURY AGO.
THE MAJORITY OF THE COURT
RULING, THE CONSTITUTION
PROTECTS A PERSON'S RIGHT TO
CARRY A GUN OUTSIDE THE HOME.
JESSICA SCHNEIDER IS LIVE IN
WASHINGTON WITH THESE BREAKING
DETAILS.
JESSICA, WHAT MORE WAS IN THIS
DECISION?
>> ERICA, THE SUPREME COURT HERE
SIGNIFICANTLY EXPANDING GUN
RIGHTS AND EXPANDING THE SCOPE
OF THE SECOND AMENDMENT FOR THE
FIRST TIME SINCE 2008.
SO THIS IS A 6-3 DECISION
WRITTEN BY THE SENIOR MOST
JUSTICE, CLARENCE THOMAS.
WHAT IT HAS DONE IS IT HAS
STRUCK DOWN A NEW YORK GUN LAW
THAT YOU RESTRICTED WHO COULD
CARRY CONCEALED HANDGUNS OUTSIDE
THE HOME.
IT'S A LAW THAT STOOD FOR MORE
THAN A CENTURY.
BUT THE COURT HAS NOW SAID THAT
THAT LAW CANNOT STAND AND THAT
CRUCIALLY HERE THE CONSTITUTION
GUARANTEES THE RIGHT TO CARRY A
GUN OUTSIDE THE HOME.
THAT'S SOMETHING THE SUPREME
COURT HAS NOT SAID BEFORE.
THE COURT ALSO SAYING THAT
STATES WILL BE RESTRICTED FROM
THE TYPES OF RULES THAT CAN'T
THEY CAN ENACT WITH GUNS.
SO REALLY THIS DECISION NOT ONLY
STRIKES DOWN THE NEW YORK LAW
AND SIX OTHER STATES THAT HAVE
LAWS THAT ARE BASICALLY
IDENTICAL TO THIS NEW YORK LAW,
BUT IT ALSO PUTS STATE LAWS IN
JEOPARDY THAT ARE SIMILAR TO
THIS LAW WHICH REQUIRED PEOPLE
TO SHOW PROPER CAUSE WHEN THEY
APPLY FOR PERMITS.
AND IT WILL ALLOW SCRUTINY FOR
ALL GUN LAWS, ASSAULT WEAPONS,
AGE RESTRICTIONS, RESTRICTIONS
ON MAGAZINES.
WHILE IT STRIKES DOWN THE LAW,
IT INSTITUTES A NEW FRAMEWORK
FOR COURTS TO EVALUATE GUN LAWS
ALL OVER THE COUNTRY, AND THE
DISSENTING JUSTICES -- THIS WAS
A 6-3 DECISION -- SO THE COURT'S
LIBERALS DISSENTED.
WHAT STEPHEN BREYER AS THIS
BURDENED STATES' EFFORTS TO CURB
GUN VIOLENCE BECAUSE THIS WILL
CALL INTO QUESTION GUN LAWS
ACROSS THE COUNTRY.
WHILE THIS STRUCK DOWN THE
NEW YORK LAW, THERE WAS A
CONCURRENCE FROM JUSTICES ALITO,
KAVANAUGH, AND CHIEF JUSTICE
ROBERTS AND IT SAID THIS HOLDING
DECIDES NOTHING ABOUT WHO MAY
LAWFULLY POSSESS A FIREARM.
SO THEY ARE SAYING THERE ARE
SOME LIMITS TO THIS DECISION,
BUT REALLY, ERICA, THIS DECISION
IS WIDE RANGING.
IT WILL CALL INTO QUESTION LAWS
ALL OVER THE COUNTRY WHILE MOST
IMMEDIATELY STRIKING DOWN THIS
NEW YORK LAW AND LAWS IN SIX
OTHER STATES JUST LIKE IT THAT
HAD VERY SPECIFIC DEMANDS ON
PEOPLE WHEN THEY WERE APPLYING
TO ACTUALLY GET A LICENSE FOR A
CONCEALED HANDGUN IN PUBLIC.
AND AGAIN, ERICA, THIS HAPPENING
IN A STATE WHERE WE SAW A MASS
SHOOTING RECENTLY AT A BUFFALO
SUPERMARKET AND HAVE POPULATED,
CONCENTRATED AREAS LIKE NEW YORK
CITY WHERE THE POLITICIANS THERE
ARE WORRIED ABOUT PEOPLE HAVING
CONCEALED HANDGUNS AND GOING
INTO THESE VERY POPULOUS PLACES.
>> THAT'S EXACTLY WHAT YOU HEAR
FROM OFFICIALS HERE.
JESSICA, APPRECIATE IT.
THANK YOU.
>>> ALSO WITH US, CHIEF LEGAL
ANALYST JEFFREY TOOBIN.
LET'S START WITH YOU.
AS JESSICA BROUGHT UP THERE,
HERE IN NEW YORK CITY WE ARE
STARTING TO SEE SOME REACTION.
WE'RE HEARING FROM, FIRST AND
FOREMOST, THE BROOKLYN D.A. WHO
CALLED THIS A NIGHTMARE FOR
PUBLIC SAFETY, SAYING NEW YORK'S
STRONG GUN LAWS HAVE SAVED LAWS
FOR OVER A CENTURY AND IT OPENS
DOORS FOR EVERYONE TO JEOPARDIZE
PUBLIC SAFETY.
THIS OPENS UP A CONVERSATION
ABOUT POLICING VERSUS THESE
RIGHTS, AND WE'LL HEAR MORE OF
THAT IN THE WAKE OF THIS
DECISION.
>> WE SURE ARE.
AND I THINK IT'S IMPORTANT TO
EXPLAIN JUSTICE THOMAS'S
REASONING, WHICH IS, I THINK A
LOT OF PEOPLE UNDERSTAND THE
FIRST AMENDMENT IN THE SENSE
THAT EVERYONE KNOWS THAT YOU AND
I, WE DON'T NEED A PERMIT FROM
THE GOVERNMENT TO HAND OUT A
LEAFLET IN TIMES SQUARE THAT
SAYS BIDEN FOR PRESIDENT OR FOR
PRESIDENT.
THE GOVERNMENT IS NOT ALLOWED TO
REGULATE SPEECH IN THIS COUNTRY
EXCEPT IN VERY NARROW
CIRCUMSTANCES.
WHAT JUSTICE THOMAS SAYS
REPEATEDLY IN THIS OPINION IS
THE SECOND AMENDMENT IS JUST
LIKE THE FIRST AMENDMENT, THE
GOVERNMENT MAY NOT REGULATE
INDIVIDUAL POSSESSION OF WEAPONS
FOR SELF-DEFENSE, JUST LIKE THEY
CAN'T REGULATE THE SPEECH OF
PRIVATE CITIZENS.
THAT'S A VERY DIFFERENT APPROACH
TO THE SECOND AMENDMENT AND TO
PUBLIC SAFETY THAT THE SUPREME
COURT HAS HELD PREVIOUSLY, AND
IT'S CERTAINLY A VERY DIFFERENT
APPROACH THAN THE STATES THAT
ARE ATTEMPTING TO DEAL WITH GUN
VIOLENCE -- ARE PUTTING FORTH
NOW.
NOW, THERE IS THIS, I THINK,
SOMEWHAT BIZARRE CONCURRING
OPINION BY JUSTICE KAVANAUGH
WHERE HE SAYS, NO, NO, NO, THERE
STILL IS THE POSSIBILITY FOR
SOME SORT OF BACKGROUND CHECK
RULES, BUT THAT DOES SEEM
INCONSISTENT WITH WHAT THE
MAJORITY HOLDS, EVEN THOUGH
JUSTICE KAVANAUGH IS PART OF THE
MAJORITY.
BUT WHAT'S CLEAR, WHAT'S
ENTIRELY CLEAR FROM TODAY'S
OPINION IS THAT IT IS GOING TO
BE MUCH MORE DIFFICULT FOR
STATES AND LOCALITIES TO
REGULATE ANY SORT OF GUN
POSSESSION, GUN BACKGROUND
CHECKS THAN IT WAS PREVIOUSLY.
>> ERIC RUBEN, AS WE LOOK AT THE
DIFFICULTIES, SHOULD WE BE
PREPARING FOR A FLURRY OF
LAWSUITS TO CHALLENGE EXISTING
LAWS IN STATES THAT DO ATTEMPT
TO REGULATE THAT?
>> YEAH.
I THINK ONE OF THE INTERESTING
THINGS ABOUT THIS OPINION IS
THAT NOT ONLY DID THE COURT
STRIKE DOWN NEW YORK'S
REQUIREMENT FOR HEIGHTENED NEED
FOR SELF-DEFENSE BEFORE YOU CAN
GET A PERMIT, BUT THEY APPLIED A
METHODOLOGY THAT'S DIFFERENT
THAN THE LOWER COURTS HAVE BEEN
APPLYING, IN PARTICULAR, IT SAID
THAT LOWER COURTS HAVE BEEN
DOING IT WRONG.
HISTORY AND TRADITION ALONE IN
CONJUNCTION WITH THE SECOND
AMENDMENT SHOULD BE GUIDING THE
COURTS.
AND ONE OF THE BIGGER ISSUES
THAT THIS PRESENTS IS THAT OVER
THE PAST 13 YEARS SINCE THE
DISTRICT OF COLUMBIAV. HELLER
CASE IN 2008, COURTS HAVE BEEN
ADJUDICATING ALL SORTS, MAGAZINE
POSSESSION, AND THEY HAVE BEEN
ADJUDICATED UNDER A DIFFERENT
STANDARD OF REVIEW.
ONE OF THE SLEEPER ISSUES, I
THINK, IS IT POTENTIALLY OPENS
THE DOOR TO A NEW ROUND OF
LITIGATION, NOT JUST ABOUT
PUBLIC CARRY RESTRICTIONS, BUT
ALL FIREARM RESTRICTIONS.
>> IN TERMS OF THOSE
RESTRICTIONS --
>> I JUST -- IT'S WORTH TALKING
ABOUT JUST A LITTLE BIT WHAT
JUSTICE THOMAS MEANS BY
"HISTORY."
THERE'S A VERY LONG SECTION IN
HIS OPINION ABOUT WHAT DID THE
FRAMERS THINK ABOUT WHAT THE
RIGHT TO KEEP AND BEAR ARMS
MEANT.
AND SO WHAT JUSTICE THOMAS IS
REALLY SAYING IS THAT EACH COURT
THAT EVALUATES GUN REGULATIONS
HAS TO DECIDE WHAT DID JAMES
MADISON THINK ABOUT AR15s, WHAT
DID JAMES MADISON THINK ABOUT
RED FLAG LAWS?
NOW, JUSTICE BRIAR, WHO
DISSENTED, SAID, LOOK, THAT IS
NOT THE WAY WE SHOULD READ THE
CONSTITUTION.
BUT THAT'S -- THAT'S THE WAY
JUSTICE THOMAS READS IT, AND
THAT'S THE MAJORITY OPINION.
>> BUT THAT'S SO MUCH OF WHERE
WE'RE AT.
WHEN WE LOOK AT THE MAKEUP OF
THE COURT NOW, THIS IS SOMETHING
THAT CONSERVATIVES -- THIS HAS
BEEN A PLAN AND AN AGENDA FOR
DECADES, AND THERE IS NOW A
CONSERVATIVE-DOMINATED COURT.
THAT WAS THE GOAL OF THE
FEDERALIST SOCIETY, AND PART OF
THAT INCLUDES THIS HISTORICAL
LENS WHICH MAY OR MAY NOT MAKE
SENSE TO SOME PEOPLE, BUT
THERE'S MORE AND MORE OF THAT.
>> TO BE SURE.
I MEAN, YOU KNOW, THE
CONSERVATIVE APPROACH TO
INTERPRETING THE CONSTITUTION IS
GENERALLY KNOWN AS ORIGINALISM,
VERY MUCH ASSOCIATED WITH
JUSTICE SCALIA WHO SERVED ON THE
COURT FOR MANY YEARS, WHICH IS
THE IDEA THAT THE WORDS OF THE
CONSTITUTION, THE ONLY WAY --
THE ONLY LEGITIMATE WAY FOR THE
COURT TO ANALYZE THE
CONSTITUTION IS TO ANALYZE THE
WORDS AS THEY WERE UNDERSTOOD
WHEN THE CONSTITUTION WAS
RATIFIED IN THE LATE 18th
CENTURY.
SO THE JOB FOR JUDGES NOW IN
2022 IS TO DECIDE WHAT DID
THE -- WHAT WOULD THE FRAMERS
THINK ABOUT REGULATION OF AR15s.
YOU KNOW, FIRST OF ALL, IT'S
VERY DIFFICULT TO DO.
SECOND, YOU KNOW, IT'S REALLY
HARD TO KNOW WHAT JAMES MADISON
WOULD THINK ABOUT AR15s.
BUT THE SUPREME COURT HAS LAID
DOWN THAT'S THE RULE NOW.
THE CONSTITUTION HAS TO BE
INTERPRETED, THE SECOND
AMENDMENT IN PARTICULAR, BASED
ON WHAT THE FRAMERS WOULD HAVE
THOUGHT ABOUT THIS REGULATION,
AT LEAST ACCORDING TO JUSTICE
THOMAS.
THE ANSWER ALMOST ALWAYS IS THE
FRAMERS WOULD HAVE THOUGHT THAT
THE INDIVIDUAL HAD THE RIGHT AND
THE STATE DIDN'T HAVE THE RIGHT
TO REGULATE.
BUT THAT'S WHAT ALL THESE CASES
ARE GOING TO BE ABOUT, AND THE
ONE THING WE KNOW FOR SURE IS
THERE ARE GOING TO BE A LOT MORE
CASES CHALLENGING ALL SORTS OF
GUN RESTRICTIONS, NOT THE NEW
ONES THAT WERE PASSED IN LIGHT
OF THE MASS SHOOTINGS, INCLUDING
THIS NEW Y